En este capítulo exploraremos
cómo las computadoras cuánticas y clásicas
trabajan juntas para resolver uno de los desafíos más importantes
en ciencias: estimar con precisión la energía de moléculas y materiales
Podemos lograrlo
usando un quantum circuit
para generar estados de muestra
que luego procesaremos
y diagonalizaremos con una familia de algoritmos
En esta familia de rutinas
como SQV y SKG, hay un curso completo en
la plataforma IBM Quantum dedicado
a ellos y a métodos relacionados
Para nuestros propósitos en esta lección
daremos una explicación breve
Independientemente de si usas SQV o SKG,
tu objetivo es encontrar los vectores propios
y valores propios de una matriz hamiltoniana
Esta matriz puede describir la energía de un sistema físico
o químico, pero el mismo marco de trabajo
puede abordar muchos otros tipos de problemas,
como la logística. A veces
estas matrices son enormes,
por lo que reducir las dimensiones
de la matriz preservando las características importantes
del estado fundamental
puede ser extremadamente valioso. Ese es el objetivo en SQV:
usamos la computadora cuántica para generar un subespacio útil,
uno que contenga el estado fundamental.
Luego podemos proyectar nuestra matriz hamiltoniana
sobre ese subespacio, lo que nos deja
con una matriz pequeña que será
mucho más fácil de diagonalizar
usando computación clásica de alto rendimiento. Lo hacemos
preparando un estado cuántico de prueba,
llamado comúnmente ansatz,
y realizando mediciones para muestrear ese ansatz
en la base computacional. Eso nos da
un subespacio muestreado en la base computacional,
pero lo que realmente queremos encontrar
es el verdadero estado fundamental. ¿Qué pasa
si nuestro subespacio muestreado no contiene
todos los componentes necesarios?
Si elegimos un mejor ansatz,
podríamos obtener una mejor estimación del estado fundamental.
Eso nos lleva al método basado en muestras
llamado diagonalización cuántica krylov, o SKQD. En SKQD,
comenzamos con un ansatz
como antes, pero luego aplicamos quantum gates que aproximan
la evolución temporal de un sistema físico.
Se puede demostrar que, con algunas suposiciones,
esto garantiza la superposición entre el ansatz con evolución temporal
y el verdadero estado fundamental.
Ambos algoritmos parten de matrices
hamiltonianas enormes. Funcionan de manera algo diferente,
pero en ambos casos la parte cuántica del algoritmo produce
un subespacio que nos permite reducir nuestra matriz,
en el que esperamos preservar las características clave del estado fundamental.
Entonces, ¿dónde entra la computación clásica de alto rendimiento?
Para los hamiltonianos más grandes
y para las estimaciones más precisas del estado fundamental,
incluso estas matrices proyectadas pueden ser bastante grandes.
Por eso, aprovechar computadoras clásicas más potentes
puede ayudarnos no solo
a obtener mejores resultados,
sino también permitiéndonos abordar problemas más grandes.
Para unirlo todo,
podemos representar los algoritmos basados en muestras
como una combinación de diferentes modelos de programación
sobre un conjunto de recursos heterogéneos.
Por ejemplo, podemos representar nuestro algoritmo
como un flujo de trabajo de tareas, donde tendremos una tarea
para la preparación del quantum circuit que se superponga
con nuestro estado objetivo, seguida de una tarea
de transpilación, que solo requiere recursos clásicos
para ejecutarse. A continuación vendrá la tarea
que usa primitivas para ejecutar nuestro quantum circuit,
lo cual obviamente requiere un quantum backend.
Y luego tendremos una tarea de postprocesamiento que en sí misma
podría ser un algoritmo de diagonalización en paralelo
ejecutándose en múltiples nodos.
Además, puede que queramos ejecutar
uno de esos algoritmos muchas veces
mientras variamos nuestro ansatz,
o ejecutarlos completamente en paralelo
con diferentes poblaciones.
Ahora unámoslo todo con SKQD
en código. Aquí están todos nuestros archivos de tareas,
y aquí todos nuestros archivos de envío.
En la tarea de mapeo preparamos los circuits.
En el paso de optimización ejecutamos los circuits de la mejor manera.
En la tarea de ejecución tomamos muestras de la distribución
desde el estado preparado por
nuestro ISA circuit.
Lo obtenemos del paso anterior
y realizamos nuestro postprocesamiento.
Así que ya estamos listos para enviar nuestro
flujo de trabajo de Qiskit.
Como puedes ver, todo se ejecuta en secuencia
con dependencias. Esperemos
los resultados y revisemos los archivos de salida.
Aquí está el archivo de salida del paso de optimización,
donde tenemos nuestro ISA circuit.
Y finalmente revisemos nuestra integración
de extremo a extremo.
Del schedule.
Y eso es todo para la demostración rápida del flujo de trabajo de SKQD.
Todo el código estará disponible en la sección de texto
o en la descripción a continuación.
Y con eso ya hemos repasado algunos
conceptos y ejemplos que pueden ayudarte a empezar con
la gestión de programas híbridos complejos. Por supuesto,
si te gusta esto, solo estamos arañando la superficie de
todo lo que puedes hacer con la combinación de recursos
cuánticos y clásicos específicos. Para explorar más,
consulta la documentación y los tutoriales
en la plataforma IBM Quantum,
y asegúrate de revisar los recursos compartidos en la sección de texto
o en la descripción para más herramientas
y software. Gracias por ver.
Sí, eso es todo.